hey 42 here there is a soulmate for
everyone
somewhere out there on our vast blue
planet there is a single person who is
your perfect over half it doesn't matter
if you have the face of a sea cucumber
and the personality of a cabbage there
is someone out there who will love you
for who you are and fall into a lifetime
of eternal undying love at least that is
what Hollywood movies poetry and endless
novels would have you believe
and what billions of people genuinely
think but what's the truth what is the
real science behind soulmates and love
at first sight do soulmates that she
exists is a soulmate as a social
phenomenon actually possible let's find
out once and for all and whether your
love interest is meant to be or whether
there's something more rational going on
behind the scenes what you're about to
learn will change how you look at love
forever you have been warned but first a
quick word about today's sponsor
footmouse do you still play video games
with your hands well you're putting
yourself it's a huge disadvantage
recently I've been using footmouse and
frakking noobs left right and center
don't believe me take a look for
yourself at this innovative new product
introducing a revolution in gaming the
first science-based gaming mouse I've
been using foot mouse since 2017 but not
on land there's a lot of controversy as
to whether or not Foot mouth should be
tournament legal it's just such a huge
advantage but it's still all about skill
but Mouse just raises the skill gap foot
your foot in the game and the best part
about all this is that foot Mouse is
sponsored by raid Shadow legends I'm
sure you've already heard about rage
hunter legends by now but there has
never been a better time to start
playing because the daily log in rewards
program for new players has just been
doubled from 90 to 180 days I love it
and you can play raid both on mobile and
on your desktop this is amazing because
every day you can claim a free reward
from energy refills silver and gems to
shards under free barbarian legendary
champions skill of the drink I've been
playing the campaign mode a lot you have
to get the perfect combination of
champions and items to win which is
really fun to play around with it's
always exciting opening a new shot to
see which new champion you're going to
get and the tavern mode is fantastic you
can easily upgrade your new champions by
sacrificing your old ones you can find
me in the game under the nickname 42 if
you're quick enough you can also join my
club so what are you waiting for
go to the video description click on the
special links and if you are a new
player you will get two hundred thousand
silver plus one free champion Grinner
all this treasure will be waiting for
you here these rewards will only be
available for new players for the next
30 days so don't delay good luck and
I'll see you there thanks her rage
shadow Legends for sponsoring today's
video and I'm very very sorry to say but
footmouse does not exist okay so before
we discover whether soul mates actually
exist and I reveal a secret formula for
finding yours let me ask you a question
what percentage of people do you think
genuinely believe that soul mates exist
as in there is one and only one perfect
person out there for everyone take a
wild guess is it 30% 40% 50% perhaps try
73% that's right research has found that
a staggering 73% of Americans believe in
soulmates
that's higher than I would have thought
but what really shocked me is that a
slightly higher percentage of men
believe in soulmates than women but did
you know that whether or not you believe
in soulmates effects
you will approach relationships and how
looking you will be in love and it all
depends on your true love mindset when
it comes to relationships there are two
kinds of people those who have a destiny
mindset and those with a growth mindset
a destiny mindset means you believe in
the inherent power of the universe or
perhaps a deity to bring you and your
true love together essentially you
believe in soulmates on the other hand
those with a growth mindset believe are
strong evergreen relationship is not
just found it has to be worked on over
time and built up from nothing they also
believe that there are many more than
just one potential mate for everyone out
there
those with a destiny mindset tend to be
more impulsive and passionate they fall
into relationships easier and when they
do the initial period is always fiery
intimate and intense but these
relationships can fall apart just as
easily destiny inclined mindsets tend to
be much more put off by their partners
faults they view any faults big or small
as an indication that they are perhaps
not their soulmate because well a true
soulmate wouldn't have any faults would
they if there are any signs that a
relationship doesn't fall neatly into
their preconceived idea of what their
romantic destiny should be then they
usually end the relationship as a result
those with a destiny mindset go through
more relationships during their lifetime
which is somewhat ironic and even more
ironically one study actually found that
couples in a relationship who both have
a destiny mindset and genuinely believe
they are made for one another are
according to the statistics unhappy in
that relationship much more
off those with a growth mindset however
do things in the complete opposite way
once they have found someone they are
romantically inclined towards they will
work at building a relationship with
that person if hiccups do occur they are
much more likely to work to solve them
and when they encounter things they
don't like about their partner that
usually learn to love it or accept it as
a part of a healthy relationship because
every single relationship does have
issues there are always those quirks
about our partners that we initially
find cute but after a while a annoy the
[ __ ] out of us that's entirely normal
and it depends on your mindset destiny
or growth whether you will Bend that
partner once those quirks begin to annoy
you growth mindsets have longer and more
stable relationships than destiny
mindsets a growth mindset to go through
fewer partners before permanently
settling down they also work harder a
relationships for example they do more
to appease or accommodates their
partner's needs
whereas destiny mindsets typically do
the opposite because they assume if it's
meant to be then things will work
themselves out naturally anyway without
putting in the hard work
so before we shortly ruin romantic
novels forever and discuss the science
behind soulmates let's see if there are
any scraps of evidence to prove that
they in fact do exist for the sake of
clarity I'm defining a soulmate as there
being only one person in the world who
is in every way perfect for another
individual well the only way one could
attempt to prove the idea of a soulmate
is by approaching it from either a
philosophical or spiritual angle with
current technology it's not possible to
definitively quantify whether a person
is without any doubt a person's soul
mate because to do that we would have to
computationally model those two people's
personalities
memories and ambitions for the future
essentially we would have to download
their brains then we would have to
somehow create an algorithm that takes
those two models and outputs a romantic
suitability score which would be
exceedingly difficult because how one
defines romantic suitability differs
vastly based on opinions and cultures
but even that wouldn't be enough because
once we have that score it's completely
meaningless without something to compare
it against such as a standardized mean
of all potential scores so Dave and
Susie may have a romantic suitability
score of five point six okay is that
good but high blow about average since a
person's soul mate could be anyone we
would have to create a computer model of
every single person in the world or at
least every person who is to test
subjects preferred to gender and within
a reasonably similar age range then we
would have to run our algorithm against
every single one of those person's brain
models which could easily be anywhere
from half a billion to two billion
people then we could compare the results
and whichever person has the highest
suitability score with the initial test
subject would be that person's one and
only soulmate obviously this is
completely impossible today perhaps in
ten or so years when we have the
technology to easily create computer
models from people's brains and we have
the unfathomably huge computational
power required to store and process all
of those models such an experiment could
become reality
I envision that one day you may be able
to pay a company to do exactly that for
you perhaps through a dating app and
work out which one person out of the
entire world's population
is scientifically most romantically
suited to you like the map score
currently on online dating sites but
leveraging more than a trillion times
more data and algorithmic might until
that day comes we cannot scientifically
prove that there will in fact be just
one person who is perfect for each of us
it may be the case that there are many
potentially many thousands of equally
suitable candidates out there so what
does the maths have to say about
soulmates
well when broken down it gets really
interesting in his fascinating book
what if randall munroe does exactly that
he took the question what if everyone
actually had only one soulmate a random
person somewhere in the world and
answered it like so let's suppose you
like eyes with an average of a few dozen
new strangers each day if 10% of them
are close to your age that's around
50,000 people in a lifetime given that
you have 500 million potential soulmates
it means you'll only find true love in
one lifetime out of 10,000 so basically
what he's saying is that mathematically
if soulmates existed the chance of you
meeting yours over your entire lifetime
would be close to zero this means that
if everyone were to agree to only
procreate with their soulmate and settle
for nothing less
the vast majority would be so
unsuccessful in this endeavor that the
human race would die out in only a
couple of generations so soulmates don't
exist
obviously mathematically they cannot in
fact as a rough estimate less than 0.01%
of people in relationships who claim to
have found their one true soulmate
actually have sorry but what if I told
you there is a way you can actually find
your soulmate in just a few months
using a simple algorithm well such an
algorithm exists and I'll tell you
exactly how to use it shortly but first
a quick but necessary segue on the
mechanics of love
usually people attempt to find their
soul mate in a linear way which is
incredibly inefficient typically we go
on dates until we find someone suitable
enough for a long-term relationship
which usually breaks down after a few
weeks or a few years get this the
average relationship is only two years
and nine months after a few
relationships there may be a marriage
but only half of all marriages are until
death do us part this process can take
decades before finding the one
eventually most people after many duds
and perhaps a failed marriage or to do
finds that person they're happy enough
to stay with for the remainder of their
life if you think you're already in that
position then congratulations but are
they actually your soul mates I've
talked about what love is in a previous
video but to put it succinctly
it's a neurochemical memory enhanced
bond with another person formed after
repeated exposure catalyzed by the
release of hormones such as testosterone
estrogen dopamine norepinephrine
serotonin oxytocin and vasopressin and
you thought I couldn't do dirty talk the
fingers this chemical bonding process
can occur with potentially millions of
people multiple but similar studies have
shown how two strangers staring into one
another's eyes for four minutes can make
them both feel as though they're in love
there have even been some marriages off
the back of such experiments so after
your exhaustive dating relationship and
breakup cycle how do you know the person
that you eventually settle down with is
the one well you don't
it may sound cold
the truth is you could have quite
probably and rather comfortably settled
down with at least thousands of other
similar individuals sure you're happy
and you're in love but how can you
confidently say there is not someone
else out there or multiple people who
you'd have more in common with feel more
comfortable around find more attractive
and argue with less over the long term
you can't or can you mathematicians have
developed an algorithm to do exactly
this find your soulmate or at least very
close to your ideal partner in a
fraction of the usual time like we
talked about earlier using current
technology there is no way to actually
find your optimal partner as if every
person alive there are just too many
variables and too many people out there
and realistically most people can only
date between 50 to 100 people in a
single lifetime but by using the
following mathematical technique you can
completely close to it and find someone
at least 99 percent of the way to your
perfect soul mate in well under 100 days
however it's going to require you to be
rather cold and not get sidetracked it
goes like so first you date 10 people
who you find mildly attractive and fit
your basic criteria for a spouse after
each date you reject them no matter how
much you feel like they could be the one
you simply say no thanks and move on
then you rank all 10 dates and then you
take the first person on that list your
number one most preferred date and you
simply remember them
next you keep going on more dates and as
soon as you go on a date with someone
who outranks your number one from the
first group of ten that is your soul
mate at least that is the closest you
can come to finding your soul mate in a
single human lifetime with limited
resources and limited time to go on a
limited number of days mathematicians
call this method optimal stopping theory
and this is mathematically proven to be
the optimal way to find your best
available partner with the least amount
of effort or wasted time so have fun out
there and I won't be held responsible
for any ruined relationships as a result
of watching this video thanks for
watching and don't forget to check out
the sponsor rage Shadow legends